right uh we'll go ahead and get started
so uh
this is entity framework core unchained
um
getting the best performance from your
orm
the spoiler is not don't use entity
framework core
so just want to get that out of the way
um so we're going to start out uh we're
going to talk about configuration um
arguably one of the more important
pieces is making sure you've got your
configuration right
talk a little bit about access patterns
any framework does some very interesting
things with some crud operations
we'll learn about
the really really easy foot guns to find
and there are a couple
we are of course going to touch on
database design because
if you have a poor database design
nothing else that i'm talking about is
going to matter
um
and then uh lastly we're just gonna have
some honest conversation about things
you shouldn't do with the f core i've
got a couple of war stories there um
including a recent one where i did not
follow my own advice
he's good
right uh who am i uh so my name is dan
malott i'm a senior principal for west
monroe uh in our product engineering
practice west monroe is a business and
technology consulting firm based
primarily in the united states we
recently opened an office here in london
they're primarily focused with mergers
and acquisitions i.e making money off of
other people's work
there are less charitable ways i can
describe it
i've been developing software since 2011
in various capacities uh
my first job i was the dba
uh
not necessarily voluntarily
um but now i primarily do development
work
although a lot of times that means
developing powerpoints
uh primary experience in microsoft i've
also unfortunately written that four
letter language
and i am a usa hockey referee i put ice
in parentheses because hockey here means
something different
than it does in the united states
right twitter github linkedin
if you want to get a hold of me
right
so i'm gonna assume you guys all know
this but i'm gonna go over it anyway um
so
any framework core is made up of two
components uh there's an object
relational mapper
which is taking the results of queries
and mapping them into net objects
whether those be records or pocos or
what have you right
and then the other piece of it is a
really really powerful query generator
that translates your link or link q
statements into
a sql that's actually executed on the
database
or whatever query language happens to be
right if you're using cosmos that might
be different
and the query generator is
both
the solution and the source of many of
our issues
um and i'll talk about that as we go on
but suffice to say that writing a query
generator that is going to generate
something that executes against every
version of sql going back to like i
guess 2005
is a difficult challenge
right
so let's talk about configuration right
so when you go to
add entity framework to your application
and you go consult the microsoft docs
you get something that looks an awful
lot like this
which is great it's easy it's a
one-liner who doesn't like a one-liner
of code right
that's why we see nested ternaries
everywhere
um and so it's really just
we have the db context it's registered
in our dependency injection container
i'm using
net apis not in the minimal
mode here clearly
connection string
in this case stored in a configuration
object
and we're good to go right it works
and it does just work
um there are some things that are
probably happening under the hood or
that are happening under the hood that
you may not
actually
want
uh so for one
there's no query retry who develops
applications that live in the cloud
who develop apps develop applications
that live on premise
who develops an environment that has 100
uptime on your sql server
oh good no one's lying to themselves
right
connections go down
who develops an environment where
there's a dns problem once a month
oh nobody's a million to that one either
come on it's always dns
right so query retries is important
right
and for a long time this was something
that was sort of left to
the developer to kind of handle um and
in our defaults we don't have any retry
that might be important you might want
that
um all queries are tracked what do i
mean by that so
in internal to the db context right so
the db context is our container that
holds all of our connection information
and models and all the mapping
information from the database
it will track all of the results that it
brings back
and it does this for a couple of reasons
one it does this because in theory if
you ask for the same object four times
entity framework core is again in theory
smart enough to only ask the database
for it once
right
um because nothing's changed
the other reason it does it is because
any framework core has a huge amount of
change tracking logic built into it so
that if i pull an object back from my
database make a bunch of changes to it
and call save changes it knows exactly
what to do to persist that to the
database or if i pull an object back i
don't do anything with it and call save
changes it does well you didn't do
anything so i'm not going to do anything
and this is this is really powerful
right it automates a lot of that uh
change tracking away from us
but that might not be the best thing for
your use case
um related entities are explicitly
loaded um
fine
um what is what does that mean it means
that if i have a
user that's a child to a post
it's going to load that
uh and you don't really get much logging
of errors or warnings you get a
connection failed
so sorry try again later
um
again in a production environment
it's fine
in your development environment we might
want some more information about why our
exquisitely constructed link statement
that's 40 lines long failed
right so what can we do about this um
well so first of all
there's a couple of things this isn't
all bad right
i've kind of talked about that like
there are some things that are fine and
some things that are probably not fine
right so you do want to implement a
retry policy
um you do want to use the proper
tracking behavior for your use case i
will dive into that much more in a few
minutes
you do want to log errors and warnings
in the development environment
and
[Music]
you may also want to log some sensitive
data if you were trying to make your
debugging easier
um and you don't want to enable lazier
eager loading proxies now
microsoft is so on board with that one
that those are no longer options unless
you download specific nuget packages
right um
lazy loading is where we get the n plus
one problem
where
well i
got my users i iterate all through all
their posts and now i'm like querying
the database like mad and if you're in
an on-premise environment the sand
administrator's calling you
if you're in a cloud environment your
finance department's calling you
and eager loading is i've just loaded
the entire database by loading one user
oops right so here's a suggested
configuration again this is
got an in is development flag make that
a little bit bigger
right so the first thing up there
got a retry policy in this case
four times
one second each time
now you're going to want
you know just like we've you you hear
this a lot at conferences this is
example code don't do this in production
uh
you're going to want to do something
more clever right so in a cloud scenario
um
you know you probably want some sort of
like fibonacci back off right okay one
second one second two right okay we all
know that
um but here it works fine right
um and you'll notice that error numbers
to add so
the retry comes out of the box with a
whole bunch of like the database didn't
respond you had a login error
uh
there's a couple other ones but like it
covers like your standard like six
things that a sql server might like barf
up if it just happens to not be there
um but you can add some right so like if
you get a uh
well for example if you get a key
conflict right
or if you get a lock deadlock or
something like that you can add those
uh in this case i am
putting in query tracking behavior no
tracking that's more just to illustrate
how you do that again we'll get to that
in a minute
and then uh in development we want to
log some additional things
and i do
very strongly urge you to do this at
least in your local development um if
you're shipping your logs anywhere
consult your security people first
so the first is able to enable detailed
errors so that gives us field level
errors so if for example i try to stuff
a six so in the united states all of our
postcodes are five digits right
and
if i
am taking a us-centric
approach to my database design and i've
done a car five or something like that
or varchar5
and i try to stuff say a uk postcode
into it
it's going to tell me
hey you're an idiot
or at least you didn't think this
through
sensitive data logging so that is we're
gonna get parameter values
um
really useful right like now i know that
my id of one returned nothing or my id
of one returned like caused an error and
i can go look into that in the database
don't do that in production
and then i can configure some additional
warnings so
these warnings give us a different
additional information that entity
framer core is emitting but usually not
doing anything with
and in this case
uh the two that i always care about are
a first without order by and filter
warning
uh and so that's if i do a dot first or
dot first or default and don't order buy
or filter at all
right
uh
the reason for that is
most databases order is not guaranteed
in your query results
we all know that right
or we've all had to find that out the
hard way
um
and the other one is a row limiting
operation without order by ironing right
and that's for the same reason right
order is not guaranteed so if i just
call give me the first
100 of these
give me the next 100 of these i might
get the same 100
or i might worse get like
100 and then 50 new ones
um right so these are useful things to
get an error like oops i forgot to do
this or
you know maybe there's a use case here
that i
wasn't covered in my user story but i
need to cover later on
um and there are
a huge number of additional core event
ids that get uh
emitted by any framework core some of
them are kind of like oh i executed a
query thanks
uh some of them are
marginally more useful
um
but you can go on the docs
docs.microsoft.com in the framework core
section and find out all the ones that
there are
there may be some additional that you
want to use
some of the some of the ones that
used to be optional are now guaranteed
which is kind of nice
there are also relational event ids
which tell you some additional
information about how it's
how any framework core is uh
like dealing with your model against the
database
right
so let's talk about crud
by the way i'm really easy to spot at
conferences these days i don't think i
own anything that doesn't say west
monroe on it um
it's working at a place for a bunch of
years does
right
so uh
the first thing that happens so crud is
create read update delete right okay we
all know that
so we'll take those in order and the
first thing we'll talk about is
inserting records
okay
if we insert one record we get one
insert statement
that's expected
um but if we insert more than one record
we got a merge statement
and this is against sql server
other providers will do different things
um
and so that that's sort of interesting
right like why is entity framework core
making that choice
um
and it
yeah
so
those two lines right i just added a
couple of users
called save changes
and got a merge statement
um and you can see that i'm emitting all
of the parameters okay
so you can see the data that i'm shoving
in there
and then the sql query
um so
this is a really curious choice and it's
a change in behavior who used
entity framework six or previous
okay we've got a few right so this is
different than what at any framework
traditionally framework did right
um
and it's not entirely illogical um
and for those of you who know who brent
ozar is he actually has a blog post from
a couple years ago that digs into this
much more
but essentially
so single insert statements are slow
that's true ish
inserting multiple records is more
efficient
again that's true
ish
right
as with everything it depends
um
so the result of that thinking is let's
use a merge statement to protect
ourselves from strange sequel generation
issues right because if i were to go
hand write
what it generated
i would use some sort of table valued
constructor in my insert right so that's
insert
my list of queries
and then select
and hard code all that stuff in there
right
and so they chose to use emerge instead
right because
building a table valid constructor is
weird even though
they actually are kind of doing that
um
so
it's this isn't a bad choice right um
this is
of between using merge and using a bunch
of insert statements this is fine
right
uh
in sql server merge does have some
issues with deadlocks
this statement
is not constructed in a way that you're
going to run into that particular issue
because we are just inserting to the
table
the deadlock issue happens when you're
inserting or updating
or deleting
um
but in your environment it may make
sense to force
single insert statements and we can do
this
um
so the break point is three or more
records so if you have one record or two
record you get insert statements if you
have three records you get merge
it's an odd breakpoint but i suppose
they did some testing
but you can change the max batch size
in your configuration and say my batches
are one
uh this is fine
it does
what you expect it to do now we'll get
instead of one merge statement we'll get
three insert statements we'll get into
something that's not so good side effect
of this a little bit later on
right
okay reading data i promised we were
going to talk about query tracking so
reading data we're just pulling data
back from the database
right
simplest thing you can do with an rrm
it's arguably the use case that you
should be using an orm for
um
and there's a difference right so
if you're going to simply return the
data like through an api or to
like a ui on your screen if you're in
winforms land
and you're not making any modifications
to the entities that you pull back
there is no reason to track them
zero
um
but if you're going to be modifying the
original entities
um
and saving them back
then you should use as tracking now most
of us
when we're building apis we have
discrete
um
read and update or delete or
create
endpoints you're very rarely like
pulling stuff and doing a whole bunch of
and putting it back in right in a simple
case
um
so you can mix and match these right so
you can configure your default behavior
and then on your query itself say i do
want this to be tracking or i don't want
this to be tracking right
and so it's choosing which one is your
majority use case
so
in an api situation where you're serving
a bunch of data it's going to be no
tracking and then okay well we're
actually creating so we need to track
this guy
um
updates and deletes
it kind of is what it is right
however interestingly enough
updates do not generate a merge
statement they're just updates
go figure
they always happen in single statements
so if i delete one thousand things i get
one thousand deletes if i update one
thousand things i get one thousand
updates
uh the only difference is if we mess
with our max batch size
uh
we get
either one connection or
a thousand connections
seems bad
um so again that's
want to pay attention to that
speaking of easy ways to shoot yourself
in the foot
okay
so bulk manipulation of data
bad
don't do that with any framework
uh lazy loading entities bad don't do
that with any rm
uh
using tracking for read-only scenarios
not bad but you're costing yourself
about 30 of your performance
um
may matter
and then retry policy
things fall offline for a minute so
interestingly i harp on the retry policy
because when i was putting together the
code samples for this talk i was using a
sql azure serverless which is great
because it's really cheap
it's not great because it goes to sleep
every
like 10 minutes of non-use
and then the first query that you run
after it starts up times out
while it's waking up
fun
um and then your you know app throws a
big giant exception because it couldn't
even create a connection to the database
because it wasn't awake great
right okay so uh what are some other
ways to destroy performance how many
people
run scaffold db context and just go with
it
great
don't do that
but using the auto-generated entities in
general can result in far too much data
coming back
so
uh loading too many related tables or
too few so
loading related tables.include
that adds joins to your statement it
adds complexity to your statement
if you do
like six of those
fine if you do 60 of those
write yourself a view
um
async
the async promoting model is really
really mature in.net at this
point you should use it
the async for each one that's a weird
construct but it works
and then defeating indexes by not
understanding how your database uses
them
got an example for that guy
right so what are the solutions here
right so we can project
only what we need out of a query and
entity framework core is smart enough to
only pull back what we need
yeah that's gonna result in better
performance
uh
only include the data you actually need
right so if i'm loading up a user
profile
and
i just have this like generic get user
so all my examples are from stack
overflows like users have posts right
and i always load the posts like i
probably don't need to if i'm just
showing a user's profile
um
always use async
unless you have a really good reason not
to
um and then learn a bit about how your
database engine chooses which indexes to
use
like i said we'll get into that all
right so
how can we use select to limit fields so
um
everybody in here has used stack
overflow right
yeah
okay so
in the stack overflow database the posts
table includes a whole lot of stuff
um
but say i'm just
gonna show the body of the post well i
really only need the body and probably
an id so that i can keep track of it
there's no reason to load the entire
post entity so what i can do is define
myself a custom post entity
in a different namespace
project our query right so that's what
we talked about with the select guy
that's a projection
and then we get one much smaller sql
which shows better in our log
but
two uh we get
less data coming back
right and so
the less data you send over the wire the
faster it's going to go right we can't
defeat physics
yet
um
just as an interesting thing you guys
probably noticed i used single or
default
and i got top two
which entity framework does to tell you
if it gets more than one result
so it can throw an exception at you
it's nice
um
cool
async
yeah not not a lot to say that i haven't
already said uh essentially
the top one is going to perform better
than the bottom one
all else being equal now
if you have 10 users
who cares
if you have 10 million users
you're probably going to want to do
this also if you have constraints about
like auto scaling in the cloud things
like
um
under load async is going to give you
more responsiveness that's it
uh indexing right i did mention i was
going to talk about this so indexes are
great right
how many of you have a dba group that
you get to work with
a couple okay how many of you also play
the role of the dba
we've got a couple there too
yeah
so
i have a slow query
you could put an index on it that's
going to speed it up right
scribble grabble grumble sure
um
i will say indexes will also slow
inserts updates and deletes
because you have to update the index
um
but the really important thing here is
that indexes are only used in certain
circumstances this depends on your
database engine so here we're talking
sql server specifically
if you have an index on a string field
whether that be
ansi or whether that be ascii or unicode
and you use
a wild card in your search and you start
the you start the search with a wildcard
sql server will not use your index
so
if you say
ends with
instead it starts with
you are now no longer using your index
and your query is going to be slow
now
depending on the size of your table may
not matter depending on your sla for
returning the data it may not matter
but when it does matter
it matters
right
so try to only use the with guy and
there are ways to get around that so
like
you know if this is a really common use
case you can create a computed column
and reverse your
column so that now you're just reversing
what you're searching on
um
and then uh indexes are generally not
used when you're doing an operation on
the column so for example answer count
divided by two
um
but yeah reach out to your dba team
should you have one
or you know put your dba hat on if
you're the dba too
because they want to help they really do
this
hey how can i speed up my slow query
like well can you rewrite your query no
hmm
they want to help
they really do
how are we doing on time
okay
database design how many of you are just
get to work on a product where you're
designing your database from scratch
let's go
great
how many of you have a database design
that's like 20 years old
yeah
generally clients
right because you only get one chance
and once there's data in there changing
a database is really really hard
um
it's it's a hard problem not to mention
all of the governance around it
uh right so some general guidance right
do it right the first time
for most of us that ships sailed
but you know think about the proper
design patterns
and and specifically design for your
access patterns right so
you know 20 years ago when all we had
were relational databases
it was like yes you should go full like
third normal form or whatever normal
form right
because that's a pure design
and then along came these
things called nosql databases um
for not only sql
you're not writing sql um
and all of a sudden we started to think
about like well
maybe it's okay to have some data
duplication if that speeds up our
results right
like if any of you are using cassandra
right that's the entire that's like the
entire design philosophy is you can have
like 60 copies of your data and it
doesn't matter because you get it fast
um
and then you know you have to like worry
about keeping it updated but
right but so
discard pure relational patterns when it
makes sense right so in a pure as an
example in a pure
third normal form
pattern right you would have a
country table that you look up against
and then you would have a country id on
your address
that is
silly you might have a country table
because you might need to display those
countries in a ui
but having a foreign key to your address
table is just adding overhead that you
don't actually need because you have to
do that join every time
right so why not just
chuck that text onto the address object
um
right
poor design equals poor performance um
so one of the first things i did in my
career was
moving migrating a bunch of foxpro data
um
i haven't lost my hair for nothing
into sql server
and
for those of you who know anything about
foxpro like it's fixed with and files
and
and the first attempt was we'll just
replicate that pattern in sql server
and that worked terribly so then we had
to go and like redo it
right
so poor design poor performance
uh
avoid table per type this is a kind of
this is one that is uh kind of more
challenging in some cases
um
because any framework makes it really
really easy to do
one type
one entity one poco one whatever
to each table
um
90 it's fine
but there are cases where maybe you've
split tables or
you have
like
you know something that's better
represented as an enum like in my
country example
um
that like really like the shape in the
database is not how you should be
looking at it as an object or
likewise the shape as an object is
really not how you should be looking at
in the database right so don't marry
yourself to table per type
use your databases tools right
so
these are things like views computed
columns
procedures shutter
but
doing these things can help reduce the
amount of work you're making any
framework and your database on jindoo
and then lastly and perhaps most
controversially on this slide avoid code
first tools
um i will preface that by saying code
first
for a quick start or
you know something where you're just
trying to get off the ground
or again servicing like 10 users
totally fine
uh it doesn't scale well so we have uh
an internal project that we use
to help utilities in the united states
manage people's applications for putting
solar panels on the roof
um because there's a lot of stuff that
goes into that
it's seven years old
it started out life as a
net mvc monolith with angularjs on the
front of it
and they used code first
and it was fine because this was a
really small use case with like you know
two applications a day that our local
utility was using
seven years later
now we're trying to
you know strangle the monolith break it
into services
you know we've added functionality in
microservices
and all of the sudden code first is a
giant pain because
it's in one project in our monolith
they've had to re-baseline like
i think
like 15 times
to get any sort of decent performance
so again if you're starting with it
and you need to start fast
or you're doing something small it's
fine
long term
all right so what do some of these
things look like
so as far as entity framework core is
concerned a view is just the same as a
table
um you just need to tell it it's a view
so that it doesn't try to generate so it
stops you from inserting things
um
so
stack overflow again posts have a post
type
um
now are you ever going to look at you
ever going to pull back a post without
its post type probably not
there are a couple of different ways to
solve it in this case i chose
let's just add the type and the join and
wrap it in a view
so that we aren't having entity
framework do that work every time
because
i don't have an example of the generated
sql because then it will just generate
select
the view columns right
from
our post with post type view
and it's just it it's cleaner right
and you can control
what the sequel looks like
right
uh
right code first
kind of talked about this a little bit
but
some other specific pitfalls
uh
data types
there are some really unfortunate
defaults
there is no reason to store every string
field as a unicode
um
now if you're building a big
international app many of them probably
have to be but not all of them
uh
you are left to define your indexes
um
you probably get an index on your
primary key particularly if you're using
sql server
um
but now we're adding indexes uh when
we're running our migration that's gonna
be
slow
which if you're running your migration
as part of a cicd process the last thing
you want is your cicd process to be slow
because then people won't merge and
build as often and right
uh you got it written you have to write
views manually um
so you are going to end up writing sql
there
for me not so scary for other people
maybe more scary or more annoying
um and then
code first doesn't gener generally
doesn't utilize more advanced database
features
um
again it's a size of data problem right
most of the time you're not going to
table partition most of the time you're
not using in memory tables or things
like that
you might want some user to find types
when i get to my
i shot myself in the foot story i'll
tell you about that
so let's talk about the things that
entity framework core is really bad at
lots of joins
um i
had a great example of this from entity
framework 6
that was like this wonderful arrow
pattern of a query
and i've lost the image unfortunately
but if you have a lot of joins so
include
efcor is going to struggle to produce
good sql it's just it
it's not only it looks ugly but it is
actually not optimal
um
etl
yeah so
how many of you are aware that um
rebrickable publishes a data set of all
the lego sets and pieces and minifigures
yeah got one so rebrickable.com you can
go and download the data set um and i
got tired of using stack overflow so
i said i'll use this lego data set this
is great
i like legos everybody likes legos
they have an icrd you can do it it's
really nice
and they publish it in individual csv
files so it's kind of on the user to
figure out how to get that into a data
structure right
um so download the csvs i go well this
is something small and quick
i'll just use entity framework core
for for loading it right
not kind of kind of ignoring that at
least one of the tables is over a
million rows
so i go and i write all the code and i
do some like genericization so that i
don't have to like write these
you know
write the same code 15 times
i go run
run it just on a small table first just
on like a 10 row table like okay it
works cool let me run it on everything
got to that 1 million some of them were
kind of slow got to that 1 million row
csv over 1 million rows clc
and i went oh i guess i'll go get a
coffee so i went to get a coffee
came back nope
still not done ran my little test query
like oh it's inserted like 3 000 records
it's not good
went and talked to my wife who's in the
next room
working from home is wonderful
came back
hit the hit the query
fifteen thousand
well i'll go like clean the cat box
and clean the cat box
came back upstairs my computer had gone
to sleep
and
the application stopped because i was
loading everything locally in a docker
container
see i didn't follow my own advice
so uh
yeah
don't do hpl within the framework core
it's going to be very slow and it's
going to be very painful
i rewrote it to use a table value
parameter
which you create a table type in sql
server you
shove all the data into a data table and
net and call a stored procedure and
it's an insert and it runs very quickly
and now it runs in less than two seconds
to load that one million row table
right um
don't be me follow my advice
uh
and lastly uh parameter issues
um you will know this if you run into it
and that is you know parameter issue can
be as simple as you're feeding a
unicode string in where it's an ascii
string or you're feeding ascii string in
where it's a unicode string and sql
server says well these things are close
enough i'm not going to complain about
it but i'm also not going to use an
index
thanks
um
and there there's just some times when
it's going to do the wrong thing you're
going to have to write sql to fix it
unfortunately
okay
so
the primary goal and this is really
important to remember any frame
framework core's primary goal is to is
reliable execution
right now the team has done a ton of
work
to improve performance
like if you haven't used it in a while
or if you're using an older version it
is worth updating to six
actually was worth updating to five it's
really worth updating to six
um
but it's
its goal is to be reliable
right
so the sequel it generates is not going
to be the most performant this really
matters when you're going against cosmos
db because how do we pay for cosmos db
yes by query time
great
um
the other thing
is that
the pre-compilation items
so you can now compile your queries
again with ef core six don't have a demo
for that unfortunately
um
but that can also provide some better
performance and also more uh repeatable
performance
um but the thing is there is significant
overhead associated with all of this
right it is a
full featured orm
with all the good and bad things that
that comes with
um
and
you know
that just
creates overhead
which is fine
right
if you really really need performance
raw ado or something like dapper
right
like if that if performance matters that
much use something that is closer to
essentially writing it yourself
it's going to take more work so there is
an roi there right
but
yeah that's uh
that's it
right
um
so i've gone very fast
i hope you guys have questions
uh
right so understand how it works how it
doesn't work the docs are your friends
they're really much more useful than
they used to be
you want to measure performance
and if you've done one and two
you're going to have three
which is have a plan to fix it when it
goes bump
right that happens to everybody
this thing that worked all of a sudden
doesn't work
right
all right
questions
i went very fast
no questions i
i was i was perfect
i'm gonna see nothing but greens in the
bin out there
and then all the reds in the little
tupperware thing right
um
yeah so that's that's really all i have
um if you have questions that you don't
want to ask in front of the entire room
feel free to come up and ask me
as you are leaving please make sure you
fill out an evaluation that's very
helpful for me it's very helpful for the
organizers
and thank you all very much